Traue keinem Garten in dem kein Unkraut wächst.
Kennst du den Spruch?
Den hatte ich am Anfang meiner Gartenkarriere
noch eins zu eins so unterschrieben, aber
mittlerweile mache ich das nicht mehr.
Unser Garten ist nämlich fast komplett unkrautfrei,
und wie das funktioniert, auf ganz natürliche
Art und Weise, ohne Unkrautvernichtungsmittel
oder irgendwelche Plastikfolien, das zeige
ich euch heute in diesem Video.
Falls du mich noch nicht kennst, ich bin Marie,
ich gebe Kurse rund um das Thema Selbstversorgung
aus dem Garten.
Hier auf dem YouTube Kanal spreche ich auch
ganz viel über das Thema Gemüsegarten.
Also abonniere gerne meinen Kanal und drücke
auch die Glocke, wenn du informiert werden
möchtest, sobald das nächste Video erscheint.
Ja, was ist an Unkraut denn überhaupt so
schlecht?
Daran ist erst mal überhaupt nichts schlecht.
In meinen Gemüsebeeten möchte ich aber möglichst
wenig Unkraut haben, weil die Unkräuter oder
auch Beikräuter, Wildkräuter, wie auch immer
man sie nennen mag, immer in Konkurrenz mit
den Gemüsepflanzen treten, die ja möglichst
viel Platz haben sollen in den Beeten, die
möglichst groß und kräftig werden sollen,
und die Unkräuter konkurrieren um Licht,
um Nährstoffe, um Wasser mit den Gemüsepflanzen.
Deswegen bin ich der Überzeugung, dass es
gut ist, möglichst wenig Unkräuter im Beet
zu haben.
Die können gerne überall im restlichen Garten
wachsen und sprießen, und ich freue mich
da auch sehr drüber, vor allem über seltene
Wildkräuter, über Heilkräuter und so weiter,
aber meine Beete sollen möglichst unkrautfrei
bleiben.
Das erspart mir nämlich super viel Arbeit.
Ich mag es nicht gerne, auf den Knien durch
die Beete zu robben und Unkraut zu jäten.
Ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig, und dadurch,
dass unser Garten unkrautfrei ist, spart mir
das immens viel Zeit.
Ich arbeite Vollzeit im Büro, ich habe einen
kleinen Sohn, ich studiere ökologische Landwirtschaft
und habe auch noch viele andere Hobbies und
Sachen, die ich gerne in meiner freien Zeit
mache, und deswegen finde ich es super schön,
wenn mein Garten möglichst pflegeleicht ist.
Und wenn man nicht mehr jäten muss, dann
erspart einem das so, so viel Arbeit.
Ich weiß noch, wie das vorher war, bevor
ich diese Techniken, die ich euch hier heute
zeige, angewendet habe.
Da waren meine Beete ständig zugewuchert
und ich kam überhaupt nicht mehr hinterher.
Das war einfach kein schönes Gefühl.
Ich hatte irgendwann auch gar keine Lust mehr
auf meinen Garten, und jetzt passiert das
nicht mehr, weil quasi kaum noch Unkrautrupfarbeit
anfällt.
Also ich glaube, mit drei Minuten jäten im
Monat kommen wir dicke hin, und wie das funktioniert,
das zeige ich euch jetzt.
Der Hauptgrund, warum mein Garten unkrautfrei
ist, ist, dass ich meine Beete nicht umgrabe.
Das hat ganz unterschiedliche Gründe.
Zum einen kann ein natürlich gewachsener
Gartenboden in der natürlichen Schichtung
Wasser sehr viel besser speichern als wenn
man das stört.
Dann fördert es auch das Bodenleben, wenn
man die Bodenschichten unberührt lässt,
beziehungsweise es tötet Bodenleben, wenn
man umgräbt.
Das ist in einem Biogarten auch super wichtig,
damit der möglichst fruchtbar ist, weil man
die Bodenlebewesen einfach als kleine Helfer
im Boden braucht.
Es spart super viel Arbeit, wenn man nicht
umgraben muss.
Ich hasse umgraben, es ist super anstrengend.
Ist super, wenn man sich das sparen kann,
aber es hat eben auch noch den Grund, dass
im Gartenboden, also im natürlichen Mutterboden
ein quasi unerschöpfliches Potenzial an Unkrautsamen
enthalten ist, und wenn du umgräbst, dann
bedeckst du zwar deine Unkräuter, die jetzt
auf deinen Beeten wachsen mit Erde und schaufelst
die unter, aber du holst wieder ganz viele
neue Unkrautsamen und Wurzelunkräuter an
die Oberfläche, die da anwachsen sobald da
Licht hinkommt, und ruckzuck sind deine Beete
wieder total verunkrautet.
Und um das zu unterbrechen, und um den Boden
natürlich aufzubauen und zu schonen und zu
schützen, gärtnere ich komplett ohne Umgraben.
Ich lege meine Beete mit Pappe und mit Kompost
an.
Also erst mal eine Schicht Pappe auf den Beeten
ausbringen, die nicht bedruckt ist, die nicht
irgendwelche Kleberreste enthält, und dann
bringe ich darauf Kompost aus, und so kann
man super fruchtbare Beete anlegen.
Wie das ganz genau funktioniert, zeige ich
euch zum Beispiel in meinem Gemüsegarten-Bootcamp.
Da könnt ihr euch gerne kostenlos für anmelden.
Das ist so ein kleiner Mini-Videokurs, den
ich für euch erstellt habe.
Den Link findet ihr unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Da zeige ich Schritt für Schritt wie man
diese Kompostbeete anlegt.
Die sind im ersten Jahr schon super fruchtbar,
und die bleiben jahrelang nahezu unkrautfrei.
Oft hat man das Problem, wenn man Kompost
im Gemüsegarten ausbringt, dass man damit
ganz viele Unkrautsamen und Wurzelunkräuter
wieder auf den Beeten verteilt, die man vorher
gejätet und auf dem Kompost entsorgt hat.
Deswegen entsorge ich Unkräuter jeglicher
Art, wenn sie bei uns denn mal anfallen, in
einem separaten Haufen.
Den habe ich irgendwo in einer Gartenecke.
Da schmeiße ich das dann immer drauf.
Da entsteht dann auch nach und nach ein Kompost,
und den bringe ich dann nur unter den Beerensträuchern
und den Obstbäumen aus, und mein Hauptkompost,
den ich hier an den Gemüsebeeten habe, der
bleibt komplett unkrautfrei.
Wenn du doch Unkräuter über deinen Hauptkompost
entsorgen möchtest, dann kannst du dafür
sorgen, dass die Kompostierung möglichst
heiß verläuft.
Das erreicht man, in dem man den Stickstoffanteil
im Komposthaufen erhöht und das Ganze richtig
oft umsetzt.
Dann entstehen da richtig heiße Temperaturen,
die Unkräuter abtöten.
Das wäre natürlich auch eine Option.
Ich mache das einfach so, dass ich die Unkräuter
separat entsorge und dadurch mein Kompost
komplett unkrautfrei bleibt.
Das ist natürlich super wichtig, weil sonst
kann man sich das jäten auch sparen, wenn
man die Sachen ausreist, kompostiert, und
dann einfach wieder ausbringt auf den Beeten,
dann bringt das ja nicht so wirklich viel.
Wahrscheinlich könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
wenn man nicht mehr jäten muss, dann ist
euer Garten gleich viel, viel pflegeleichter.
Wenn ihr noch mehr Tipps wollt, wie man einen
Gemüsegarten pflegeleicht gestalten kann,
dann schaut euch gerne dieses Video da oben
an.
Das verlinke ich euch gerne.
Da zeige ich euch wie wir es schaffen, dass
wir in nur drei Stunden Gartenarbeit in der
Woche unser Obst und Gemüse fast komplett
selber anbauen.
Das kann ich sehr empfehlen, das Video da
oben.
Der nächste große Tipp, wie du möglichst
unkrautfrei gärtnern kannst, ist Mulch.
Also eine organische Abdeckung, die du auf
deinem Boden um die Pflanzen herum ausbringst,
und die den Boden bedeckt hält.
Das sorgt dafür, dass da kein Licht mehr
drankommt, und dass selbst wenn in deinem
Kompost oder in deinem Boden noch Unkrautsamen
enthalten sind, die nicht aufgehen können,
und auch so kleine, fiese Unkräuter wie Löwenzahn.
Ich weiß, einige werden jetzt diskutieren,
dass man Löwenzahn ja auch wunderbar essen
kann, aber wie gesagt, in meinen Beeten mag
ich ihn nicht haben.
Dass die in den Beeten nicht wurzeln können,
weil die nur auf die Mulchschicht treffen.
Da können die landen, aber da drin können
die ja keine Wurzeln bilden, da drin können
die ja nicht aufgehen.
Deswegen decke ich meine Beete immer, immer,
immer mit ganz viel Mulch ab.
Dafür nehme ich am liebsten Holzhackschnitzel,
ich nehme auch Rasenschnitt, Stroh kann man
nehmen, Laub kann man nehmen.
Alles Mögliche, was im Garten an organischem
Material anfällt, einfach zwischen den Pflanzen
verteilen.
Ich mache da immer eine richtig dicke Mulchschicht.
Die unterdrückt nämlich auch dann, dass
das Wasser aus dem Boden verdunstet, sodass
wir nebenbei auch kaum noch gießen müssen
in unserem Garten.
Das ist ein wundervoller Effekt, deswegen
würde ich es jedem, jedem, jedem, ich weiß,
ich habe es schon so oft gesagt, aber ich
würde es jedem empfehlen, die Beete zu mulchen.
Das ist auch für das Bodenleben super.
Der Mulch verrottet nach und nach, und er
gibt noch mehr Kompost, füttere das Bodenleben,
er gibt Dünger.
Also es gibt tausend Gründe, warum man seine
Beete mulchen sollte, und das müsst ihr auf
jeden Fall ausprobieren, wenn ihr unkrautfrei
gärtnern wollt.
Und dann noch ein Tipp.
Falls doch mal Unkräuter in deinem Garten
aufgehen sollten, dann bleibe hinterher mit
dem Jäten.
So lange die noch klein sind, ist das nämlich
überhaupt kein Problem, einfach mal mit der
Hacke durch die Reihen zu gehen, und dann
ist das Ganze schon wieder erledigt.
Aber wenn die erst mal größer werden, gerade
wenn die Samen bilden, also, wenn die anfangen
zu blühen und Samen bilden, dann können
aus einer Pflanze schnell mal ein paar hundert
werden, oder sogar tausend, je nachdem was
für ein Unkraut du in deinem Garten hast.
Das solltest du auf jeden Fall vermeiden,
und dann kannst du auch gut hinterherbleiben
mit dem Jäten, wenn du einfach regelmäßig
schaust, sind da Unkräuter aufgegangen?
Und wenn da welche sind, dann jätest du die
sofort weg, dann hast du wirklich kein Problem
mehr, dass du so viel Unkraut in deinem Garten
hast, sodass du da nicht mehr hinterherkommst.
Also einfach regelmäßig durch die Reihen
gehen, dir deine Gemüsebeete anschauen, und
sobald da erste Unkräuter auftauchen, sofort
wegjäten.
Dann hast du wirklich kein Problem, dass die
so groß werden und dir das Ganze über den
Kopf wächst und du in dem ganzen Unkrautdschungel
deine Gemüsepflanzen nicht mehr wiederfindest.
So war das bei mir am Anfang.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir das jetzt hingekriegt
haben, so unkrautfrei zu gärtnern, einen
so pflegeleichten Gemüsegarten zu haben.
Also wenn du Lust hast, da noch mehr zu lernen,
dann trage dich gerne für mein kostenloses
Bootcamp ein.
Da erzähle ich auch noch viel mehr über
das Mulchen, also mit welchen Materialien
wann wie dick und so weiter.
Das ist wie gesagt kostenlos und der Link
ist unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wenn ihr noch mehr Tipps gegen Unkraut im
Garten habt, dann hinterlasst mir gerne einen
Kommentar.
Ich freue mich auch immer, neue Sachen zu
lernen.
Da drüben verlinke ich euch noch nochmal
mein Video, wo ich euch erzähle, wie wir
uns in drei Stunden komplett mit Gemüse und
Obst selbstversorgen.
Da unten findest du auch noch ein spannendes
Video, und wenn dir dieses Video hier gefallen
hat, dann freue ich mich, wenn du mir einen
Daumen nach oben gibst.
Bis gleich.
Wir sehen uns hoffentlich gleich da oder da
wieder.
Ciao!